[Music]
you are forgiven because today we have a
little bit of Poetic Justice Kendrick I
love it love that you're [__]
culture man steals a car yep with a
toddler in the back seat another one all
right another one DJ khid see what I did
there I
did Robs a Bank then he hits a tree and
he dies from injuries how's the kid
baby's fine sleeping the whole time I
like it yeah I'll take it where is this
I'll take it I believe in karma was a
baby just crying in the car seat the
whole time probably yeah was baby he had
enough time to steal the car with a
crying baby and then he went to go rob a
bank with a crying baby and then he's in
the car with a crying baby and then he
hits a tree y with a crying baby I know
LA's crazy what an cuz there's so many
freaking people right like there's a
trillion people down here 10 million to
be like precise so let's forget La maybe
12 do car robberies ever actually like
work in other places or how do you mean
what do you mean like do people get away
with it a lot of people just like ride
that car for the rest of their life let
alone bank robberies yeah they drive it
to a Chop House and it could yeah a lot
of cars I know the chop stuff for sure
there was a string of Kia robberies in
Vegas that happened like a crew just
came in and took like 20 of them in one
area 40 of them in another area it hit
like within a matter of a week dude a
car chase you can pull up into a paint
shop they'll turn it into a different
color you drive right out even while the
police are chasing you they'll never
know the difference cops saw you do it
and you're still scotf Frey even the
helicopter
leaves check this out a car dealership
opens like I don't know 18 days ago they
have their entire inventory stolen
overnight and where was Nick Cage
they're basically [__] where was Nick
Cage but no Nick C was probably doing it
that's what I'm saying no one knows
where he was did did you see that one no
I didn't the whole [__] the whole
thing dude basically all the cars except
for like two was like that was like us
[__] right after Luna
crash just looking for any kind of thing
what kind was in LA uh I don't remember
where it was you know so they did an
investigation cuz they're like where are
all these Hundai and Kia going and then
they found out that it was going to
different countries they just have a
whole system I think they found them in
like West some in Asia they would just
load them up and then boom yeah The Chop
Shop makes sense or that makes sense but
yeah cuz like VIN numbers and stuff like
well you don't believe the paint job one
all you do is swap the license plate you
press a button license plate goes yeah
you ever seen that F fous eight I sto
there that's when they steal cars
Bumblebee Bumblebee bit first when
people steal cars they to to commit a
crime they they steal the car and then
they swap the plate and then they do a
bank robbery or burglary or whatever and
then they dump the car so a lot of cars
that get stolen end up getting found
usually for a new whip yeah nobody wants
to steal a Kia just to drive it around
yeah who the [__] would do that no way
bro I don't know man the new Stingers
ain't that bad they're cool like the
design but once you park it you know you
might not see it again the tell rides I
heard those are hot hot super easy to
steal could be easier do you guys ever
feel sometimes bad for the for the
criminal yeah what
yeah totally not really what's the
context of the
story I don't know just having an
empathy Joe used to be a criminal have
okay I'm conflicted is what I'm saying
strg dud because a part of me is like um
I've been involved in burglaries and and
both a victim and thank you shout out
raise your hand if you've robbed [__]
shout out okay I've been a victim of Rob
like thieving but I've also committed
thieving right so then to me that's like
cat and mouse I've been on both sides
being so so then it's like being an
omnivore but also I make I'm not
entitled to the point where like if I
walked into someone's house and they
shot me in my mind I'm like yeah fair
game like [__] it like I played with you
got me I played I [__] around and I
found out right but then there's a bunch
of people who actually believe that
that's preposterous why did you shoot me
this water bottle is about worth my life
and it's like isn't it the same way the
same argument can be made if it's not
worth your life why are you stealing M I
have a buddy I won't name him but he I
was hanging out with him recently and he
was saying like hey I was like yeah I
have this like type of shot for my
shotgun and [__] he's like hey you
should definitely just like never use
that one use the other one that you have
because that one won't guarantee that
they die and then like Joe's saying they
might have a Shakespearean death on your
floor where they're like cursed you I
shall sue you I shall hire my lawyer and
attorneys and I will battle you out in
court sir you will see uh I was trying
to rob your your your home of course
however do uh I feel like I might have a
spark of life in me and he's like dude
just make sure they're dead just make
sure they're [__] dead so they don't
sue you yeah and I was like that's
pretty good advice I don't know I'm not
a lawyer I'm not a lawyer most robers
are Shakespearean yeah I'm not a lawyer
but can his family so sue I don't know
that they'll be motivated to right
you're just going to shoot them too will
they be
motivated will they be but will they be
motivated to maybe not they maybe
thought he deserved to shoot if you're
going to shoot the family you have to
bring the family into your house so it's
like ah so you have to kidnap them it's
less likely that that will happen and
that's what my buddy was saying but like
what Joe just did was a Shakespearean
monologue of a criminal who's like dying
in her house but like if he survives
you're you're definitely [__] so make
sure you aim for the [__] head yeah
dude head shots head shot head shots
well I think sometimes I do feel bad
because I remember I sometimes I feel I
art thou feel thy very bad oh that's so
so eloquent I feel bad if you killed
somebody on your [__] living room
would you just be like I don't know if I
want to live here anymore probably I'd
probably not feel good like that might
be kind of traumatizing that's going to
be very tra you guys take it personal
messes I to me it's like clean up cat
throw up I don't care do you guys get do
you guys take it personal when
when you when things get stolen from you
no like you know you got your scooter
jacked and [__] and like the gym got
broken into and they just stole a bunch
of random [__] and I was like this is
[__] up but it's like what are you
going to do I don't in my car it feels
invasive but I don't take it person
there's a part of you that's like angry
and you know that like okay yeah this I
got violated our space got broken into
they took our [__] but there's another
part of you that goes well like it could
have been worse and I know they're not
going I'm trying to steal barin [__]
yeah if it is like your house or you
know it might be somebody or some bad
blood that' probably piss me off but
what if somebody breaks in and steals
only your family photos yeah then some
weird [__] happening got some more [__]
what if it's my [__] bags dude Sam
bankman free detect my bags big time
dude Sam bankman freed attack the Luna
attack
us that's personal for me that's
personal for me I wake up every day I
want to see him hung dude I'm telling
you bro I want to see about revenge to
me I'm just
like Fair Play Hey no truly you know
what I mean it's like you're smart you
won truly yes in Shakespeare though
but I will have my revenge I want to see
ex it's still it's still a war now it's
a war it's still war cuz I think credit
to you but credit to me cuz I'll beat
you but credit to you for now but credit
to me for my $350 I had in Luna I think
he should be executed for that he stole
from me hung from the Rapter as I dare
say $350 dude my producer recently I was
hanging out with him he he hung out with
me for a weekend he was like dude he's
like whatever you want to do I'm down I
was like what are you talking about he's
like I'm talking about crypto I was like
oh talk and he's like you know I like
I've been doing your show for 5 years
he's like I turned like $3,000 in like
250 Grand I was
like can you say that again what did he
do he turned
$3,500 he he never told you he cashed
out no he just rode with me the whole
time and barely told he barely reminded
me that he was doing that but did he
cash out or did he also he did oh good
for him he didn't cash out all of it but
he cashed out [__] tons that's awesome
working for you because you didn't cash
out anything yes I did you remember I
told you I know I know I'm jealous it's
fine I'm jealous it's fine but no but no
but but I was like wa I forgot but then
yeah he's going to be on crypto Corner
next week but yeah I forgot I I
completely forgot but he's like yeah
dude he's like whatever you want to do
just let me know and I was like holy
[__] I completely [__] blanked on
that when someone tells me those words
that's like let's go kill somebody
that's why I thought this was that's why
I was like just H the bridge
sick and twisted talking about murdering
and robbing cars for last night sounds
like rob a bank or something thank you
I'm down to do whatever Steve hey
honestly Rider die let's go baby we're
Riders I know you I know you guys are
rers I'm not worried about Anthony's
buying woo and Koozie at [__] lunch
what were you doing piece of [__] what
were you doing I was taking thatp I was
watching I was learning a little bit I
was doing jumping jacks in the
sun it's like 99° out there I know but
it's not I've been I don't get much and
you dress like Dick Tracy yeah
I was
[Music]
naked